[Music]
we've all heard
of a condo we know what a condo is we've
heard of
luxury condo you know what a condo is
what's a condo it's a
it's a vietnamese con artist oh
because my friend's last name is dough
and he's vietnamese and his khan is like
yeah
sometimes i get it mixed up like
apartment and condo and they're like oh
this is my flat in my apartment
yeah my condo's when you can buy it
right
[Music]
apartment house can't you have rent no
no no no no no no no no no
no i'm saying what is a town is
basically a house that's connected to
others
with a condo a condo could be like an
apartment but then you own that
one like unit oh okay yeah the
townhouses i think have like multiple
floors so it feels more like a
home and there's also a pud too what's
the ph so
i think like condos like in town i think
townhouse is like uh um
the street turn but from the real estate
end they call them puds or something but
then i've also seen qd's where the walls
aren't shared
i don't know what's the iud [ __ ] oh
you put it in the pee hole
right right yep mm-hmm iuds all right so
the airport always checks if i have an
iud that means you're all the money
really it's a dui baby not the iou [ __ ]
okay anyways there's luxury condos and
there's now
the luxury wait what's the term shacks
it is uh luxury tents boxes
those luxury apartments luxury survival
condo
what oh i bet and i haven't i mean they
have those like all those
bunkers that we're getting like a
container right yeah
yeah you guys i think you guys are gonna
appreciate this oh is that awful oh
i've seen [ __ ] like this i [ __ ] love
it i don't know what wait i don't know
what i'm looking at this [ __ ] blew my
mind okay here we go
it's a hooked up bunker whoa that's so
cool
former cold war missile silo oh that's
nice inside luxury but it has windows
too
it's super rich i need sunlight off the
grid no longer means giving up a lavish
lifestyle give me some sun
go outside in camo that's where the
teletubbies
inside the security cameras armor guard
and
eight ton steel doors are the only sign
you're entering a top secret there's the
armor
this 54 000 square foot complex boasts
everything you could need to live
through the end of days
nope the survival condo is spread across
15 floors and goes
200 feet underground
are the recreation facilities like the
pet park and climbing wall
underneath that are the mechanical level
medical bay
and food stores with luxury living
quarters spread across
like a nuclear launch silo it is oh so
the full force they're right they're
retrofitted classrooms
i don't want to be around radiation a
gym and a cinema
this is a i need air i know i need
sunlight in my house i feel like this is
the way you go after you murder
something there's a picture of the
outdoors right there it's uh high-end uh
stainless steel appliances
i'll rather have a treehouse importantly
even though i'm eleven stories
underground
i've still got a window when these are
windows are all on you're coming
out of the units and you see the birds
flying and the sunset coming up and the
rain and the weather changing that's the
input your brain is used to
all but it's fake yeah yeah yeah why
is it in america it's a cool concept how
much
is that [ __ ] fifteen dollars all right
it's in kansas fifteen dollars watch it
be less than a property out in the lake
and you get like real guesses for price
25 million this is for purchase
i would say like 500. 7 500 75 million
575 million
wait wait same 575 million it was 7 500.
no i no i never i said 500
1000. 500 000 okay uh
25 million 25 million 10 million five
yeah like five ten million
oh [ __ ] point two million four point two
four five wait what the [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
dumb okay well we'll see
i've been trying to tell you five
dollars that's kitty
all right so if you want one unit okay
so each floor oh there's a unit i'm
talking about the whole thing
i've heard by the way by the way i've
been trying to tell you
okay it's a community there's multiple
units okay
okay well i was gonna leave in the city
are we in the market for buying out the
whole
the whole thing no i thought it was the
whole day i still say five minutes of
math for the whole thing no no no no
just the one just the one don't make it
complicated
15. oh no 15 floors 15 floors
there's more than 15 units for one unit
right
how many bedroom how many baths one
million per unit five
one million five million wait how many
beds
three bedrooms one i still save 500 000
per unit 500 000 per unit because i
don't think it's the cost of what it is
it's like
the exclusivity you know right only the
top tier it's in kansas too one
million dollars 1.2 million keep it
running
the error for one unit
one million ah if you say one right nice
little million i said one million
fight i said one point two million a
million i didn't say you didn't see one
i said one point two million is that one
point am i closest no
they
i would love like if they like say we
had like a i don't want
wish it but like a nuclear holocaust
yeah like have you ever played the game
fall out or heard of it no i've heard of
it
yeah so basically it's like they've had
these fallout bunkers and they've had to
like basically rebuild society in there
yeah so it's like uh i don't know
but the people that you're playing as
haven't ever been outside
so there's the kids of the people they
were born in there whoa
so then that's what they're exploring
but they literally have their own
communities and everything
so it's like that's it that's like
that's what that would be like pretty
much it's got it's pretty much got
everything so
uh so yeah one unit is a million dollars
but you have the option if you wanted to
to buy out an entire floor oh [ __ ] you
own the entire floor
3 million what's that movie what was it
where like the parents last from the
past i think
the thing in the underground house
and then like he comes out the caveman
right
he can he comes out and it's a comic
book store
i thought it was blast from the past
with the guy from uh the ice
the what's his name encino man
yeah i thought that guy right yeah it's
blasphemous and then frasier yeah no
yeah the mummy
and cenoman was the [ __ ] it was the
when they dug up that [ __ ] right
yeah yeah no no i'm talking about like
i'm saying that actor is in that movie
young [ __ ] brendan fraser yeah
he gets with a girl from pasadena
because his mom likes girls from
pasadena yes
yeah so they they sent him up so he can
go out into the world because they
needed to get something
yeah yeah also the world's still like a
very 80s movie
i missed madden frasier he was cool he
was an average but it's just like that
so that pool that's in the [ __ ]
underground
it reminds me of the pool like where
people have underground like in bunkers
and all the time it looks the same way
wait that's the thing underground
swimming pools yeah there's a lot of
people who
not a lot but there's a whole community
of people that build homes
underground like this and then they have
like pools that are like
three three four i didn't know this
actually exists i've seen like the
containers and they like they dig a big
hole and they put like the trucking
containers in
but the turn like to retrofit like some
military grade like
facility into a luxury living
arrangement
but think of the people that you're
stuck with
[ __ ] that dude i'd rather buy the whole
building and pack it with my friends
like that'd be cool if you already hate
neighbors imagine these stranger [ __ ]
neighbors that are just as paranoid as
you
oh dude i don't know we're all rich
yeah you might make it worse you're all
selfish all right there's i'd rather be
that would be adult movie they know how
to survive and not be selfish
there's eight floors of living space
so each floor has two units so it's 16
you're 16 units 16 times
1 million 16 million 16 million yeah
at the minimum because there's still the
amenities yeah cause then it's three by
eight which is
what 24 million that's true if it's true
and then but on top of that though there
is a monthly
fee hoax like pretty much an hoa right
so then the monthly fee is 2 500 bucks
well if there's fallout why the [ __ ]
would they pay a monthly fee
what well this is leading up to it
because you own it for the mercenary
soldiers that are guarding the place
yeah they're going to turn around and
shoot you and [ __ ] live inside
they probably have their own quarters
when they are yeah okay you just okay
unless they have electrocution callers
and you go you better not turn on me you
press the button to go
think about it right if money is still
existing at that point
then i think that like the world's fine
yeah the idea is you're paying for it
now
until it happens but then you still have
to have the 2500 yeah you're paying for
that now yeah so
those guards are still going out doing
whatever the [ __ ] they want well i would
only buy
the place there if the guards have the
guard level and they can't come in
anything past the guard level what if
something happens down there and they
need a song
first aid or something well they already
have it there they have the medical or
something who's going to apply the
band-aid on you you need a first aid
person
yeah but not they're not the security
that's true it's like it's like going on
a cruise right and then you still
[ __ ] you need to have workers there
well if two families like want to kill
each other they gotta break it up
maybe the residents work maybe i mean
because what are you gonna do with your
whole
the whole day i'm sure there's a rich
doctor in there wait you can leave this
place right no well this is designed
if if it goes into effect i guess they
didn't really outline like how it
exact precisely it works but if a
nuclear
war goes on oh it's just a plan b this
is
this is where you go to burrow
underground and
wait out the uh the radiation so
they they're supplying the last five
years underground but what about the
guards they're gonna die
like they're still living outside bro
you'd be really dumb though what if they
like you go there to hide from the nukes
but the other country is like oh that's
a nuclear site we gotta destroy it so
they shoot that
side over and over that one side
of the moon does it just get pounded up
top and nothing happens down there
further down and then they get go to the
middle of the earth
don't they just end up in china yeah
they pushed on the other side
dude they'll be so funny they have the
blueprints for the old nuclear
missile maps so they shoot ours that'd
be funny actually
but um but yeah so uh it's also got its
own farm
so they have the hydroponics set up so
they're actually growing their own
lettuce and like vegetables and things
like that
and then they have like a lot of
generators under there gasoline and
batteries and things like that so
for the price of a million plus the 2500
a month you're paying for
five years of survival in the event that
there's a nuclear
falls ball and i'd buy it just that'd be
like my my i don't know my savings or
something
i'm taking the truth all the drugs in
there got to get high somehow
that's true past the time yeah in five
years you're not certain if you're gonna
live or not after
true who knows if you can it's even ever
safe to go back up
yeah i think five years is not enough
time if you're that rich you probably
have every drug
[Music]
you